okay
for people who are joining this live
stream
we are looking at incremental language
development for language and we have an
assortment of topics for today
um
okay first up here
we have encrypt
and the question is should we have a
standard we have encrypt we have hash
and
what are some things that are
non-recreational so to speak that are to
do with sort of elementary ciphers
comments
i mean most of my familiarity with
elementary ciphers is either
recreational or as kind of an
introduction into cryptography
you learn something like rot
13
to understand
the basic idea of
offsetting the text but
i mean things like words 13 can be used
as
in some places like in production but
it's smashed the educational for what
i've seen
um
we don't have rock 13 listed here
well rot 13 is like cesar cipher with
key 13.
oh okay yeah
but like caesar cipher was key three but
in this implementation
there is involved from function
repository you can
put any key
okay you mean julius himself used three
as his offset well that's what
historians believe here
okay
um
okay
well so
next question this does not fit into the
encrypt framework is that true
i don't think it should
explain it even if it could like uh one
thing is that like it's only
well as it is now like cesar cipher as
it was historically is defined known for
strings of latin alphabet
encrypt does what expressions by the
rays
are we gonna redefine that or are we
gonna just error it would be a
historical to have cesar cipher work on
biter raise i agree
but but structurally
i mean
what what would be this okay so your
proposal is i mean i don't think this
should be
[Music]
is it or is it not the case
that
for every one of these things we need a
cipher type and we need a key that's
what they take
and some of them may have
more than one thing as the key
could be um not recall which exactly but
uh like transposition ciphers may have
uh
double
like two dimensions says the key not
just one integer a caesar cipher or one
string is fissioner
yeah
go ahead i was gonna say if you look at
the page for ko cipher um
the second to last one it's a
two key element this this trivial
version is just kind of showing the
existing ciphers that are on wfr that
are at least somewhat popular right
um i mean we already have things where
there's a key that has many fields
and that's how like like
symmetric keys work
right i mean i don't think we need
another or less the same fields and that
for these cybers
for each cipher the key means something
different basically
sure i mean one option is i mean i i i
agree that it probably these things
should not be integrated with the you
know existing cryptography stuff but
there is also the option that it could
kind of be like
halfway like you could have to call you
know generate classical key or something
like that but then you use it crypt
i don't know maybe that's a bad idea
also
well let's look at that i mean let's
look at like i mean clearly these are
all symmetric ciphers
and
there's no
uh you know classical public key cipher
obviously
uh presumably unless you know
um
but
what other ancillary functions are there
that hang off encrypt
that once you can do encryption you can
also do blah blah blah or all of those
things like digital signatures all
dependent on the public key aspect
well uh where in the
in cryptography as a field there are
digital signature
uh algorithms that can be based off
symmetric ciphers but
its most prominent use has been on
public key private key things
okay and also i don't think there's a
serious application of using you know
caesar ciphers to generate signatures
but i mean but i think the thing is
would be more that
uh you know if we have a mechanism for
using these these keys the workflow
should at least be similar to how it is
with
you know
modern cryptography where you generate a
key like
in in the current encrypt framework and
you generate a key and then you use it
and so on and so forth
and it seems like in this there's a
similar thing of like well are we going
to have it so you generate a key object
and then encrypt with it or are we going
to have it where you uh
you know where it's all in one big
function and it just seems like it would
be nice if the workflow is basically the
same
i kind of agree i mean the only the only
thing that's different is
if we say amazon isn't um what is it
called character encode what is it
called um the thing but the thing that
does um
um
you know uh base 64 encoding basically
code
code
okay but i mean this basin code
is not
i mean that that's just a oh we're doing
an encoding
as opposed to
which is you know arguably okay so let's
look at what this would look like if we
did it if we had a generate
um
you know let's say we had a
generate cipher key
for example
um
i mean do people call
modern
crypto systems ciphers or has that gone
out of fashion
i mean there's certainly terminology
like cipher text indeed there's cipher
text but i usually spelt with a y isn't
it
i don't think so
this is usually without no no it's okay
yeah um okay but let's say we had a
generate cipher key
and
i mean when we say generate symmetric
key
see it it's a little bit difficult to
know i mean if if we have
i mean it would be nice
go ahead
you just give it this cipher name and it
uh you know in internally has some logic
it gives you out
a specific thing that you can use as a
key for the cipher so for caesar it
would give you back an integer for
visionaire it would give you a random
string
well i don't think it would give you
just an integer would have it would be
just like generate symmetric key yeah it
gives you a symmetrical key so the
object that has like cypher ghost caesar
like p goes to integer
i kind of like this idea because because
you know in terms of teaching people
about modern cryptography right
you know having an analog in you know
elementary ciphers seems useful to me
like when i was writing the mooc i just
used the function repository ciphers and
that like worked fine
so
if you have some cypher
which would be used for all the ciphers
then it would fit the uh encrypt in
the grip framework yeah yeah sure the
first argument yeah
by the way there's
stephen on a live stream saying
fundamental problem with cryptography in
our languages there's no easy way to
save the keys you generate
no clearly explained way to preserve the
byte array for future use
how come i mean
wxf or
mx well you just serialize i mean it you
can you can just copy this you can save
this you can make an input form of this
but it sounds like a documentation
failure
on our part
like to save this by the way so it's
usable with other
you know encryption streams that
software yeah you can example export
that into file that's probably well you
can say you can say you can export it
can't you to a pem file no yet not yet
but um ah well okay then we've got at
least one person saying we need to be
able to do this
okay so because that's the thing
i mean that seems a lot higher priority
than getting you know uh you know two
thousand years later getting the julius
caesar thing working but
what is the status of getting pam file
export uh
it's in progress we are aware of that
yeah okay all right okay
but
[Music]
okay
what would happen what are the arguments
to generate symmetric key
i remember right it just basically has a
big method option
it has a password but it has a default
password right
or the first argument is the name of the
cipher and
then whatever argument is uh needed
in the metadata
that's in the method option now yeah
um
method option is kind of overkill
but i don't know maybe not
right but the main point is that with a
symmetric key
the primary thing you're doing is to
give the password you want to use and we
have a a default
you know method that's going to be used
whereas with generate cipher key
you know with these
well you don't have to give it a
password in the generate symmetric key
if you just give it a void like an empty
bracket it will generate a random key no
i know that i know that and that's what
we want to have for a
classical cipher
so you think with caesar here to
generate a random number between zero
and
if uh try to derive it from a password
that would be like very overkill but
sure in my opinion sure sure
but then
so the thing we would do here
is we'd say you know caesar three or
something and that we would have the
cipher type
followed by
the
uh
you know the specific key
for that cipher since we don't know
is that is that a fair
yeah there will be cipher key and then
cipher comma whatever data
yeah but then this would turn into
a
cipher key
that
presumably
what is that what is that color thing
representing in the case of a symmetric
key
because
it's a hash of internal data made into
this fancy colorful
things okay but but so it doesn't
so if i were to generate
if i generate
um
i generate this
and i generate that again
yeah the picture is same
if for the same key if the picture is
the same then the key is the same
and that's not a security issue
no
no it's like a hash
you cannot recreate
the key from this picture
okay what we do with a classical
what we do for the picture type thing
for the classical cipher because every
one of these every one of these objects
has like you know a different color they
use i mean when they just have its own
yeah okay so it would have a like a a a
picture of julius or something if it's a
caesar cipher
but it wouldn't contain any it would
just say cypher caesar
and um
it would contain it would be
it would i see it would it would contain
the key
if i look inside here
this this key
is the key that will be necessary to
decrypt so this is the i'm sorry i'm
just i'm just
that if if you got hold of the cipher
key
then you can decrypt everything
obviously you can both encrypt and
decrypt yeah
that's what a symmetric key is yes yes i
know but we would use cipher key rather
than symmetric key
to represent even though we could in
principle
use the symmetric key infrastructure but
we would use its own sort of cipher key
i mean maybe even a more maybe even a
more idiot-proof name like you know
historical cipher key or classical
cipher key would be
yeah
right so that nobody tries to use it to
actually encrypt something
because i i can imagine yeah exactly i
can imagine someone being kind of like
uh
you know just thinking oh a cipher as a
code is how i want to encrypt things
right you know and not knowing that
takes less space and memory
oh no all right they do the benchmarking
wow this is really the fastest way to do
this
what do we have looks like that
historical i mean um
i think we like have entities that's
more about that i don't know so rule
from alpha d
yeah right
like historical persons
yeah right
like caesar himself maybe indeed
um okay but look so so design wise
it seems like a nice thing to die it's
just such a long name i mean it just
feels like
it just
you know because if you imagine using
this in some elementary course or
something
i mean daria in your cryptography course
how
you know clearly
the wfr functions will have worked just
fine
well i use those
why does this say caesar decipher
isn't it there's a separate cipher
function it's just the same thing except
the n is negated
how would we deal with that
how would we deal with that with this
because unlike a symmetric key
where you
literally do apply it twice
that's not true with the caesar cipher
that's not always only in some crypto
systems can you apply the symmetric key
twice
yeah
like like the in
you know did the symmetric the
historical the cipher key whatever it's
called object would just contain the n
it would just say you know cipher arrow
caesar
you know uh
offset arrow 12 and then when it
encrypts it rotates right by 12 and when
it decrypts it rotates left i see
okay like we already have encrypt and
decrypt so caesar cipher and decipher is
like the same thing
right okay but so so that would be
confusing if we were to do it directly
with classical cipher that would be a
mess because we would have to have
separate encrypt and decrypt functions i
mean this is what i meant about how it
would be nice if the workflow even if
it's using different function names or
something if the workflow is at least
analogous
right
well i agree
okay
so i mean generate
actually one other advantage of the
workflow being analogous is that people
don't say oh well it's easier to encrypt
using this system where i just have to
call one function
right like if it's literally going
through the same mechanism it's clear
that you know it's also nice that we can
do file encryption and all kinds of
other things like that you know caesar
file encryption and so on
uncontrollable if we're going to let it
run on byte arrays and assuming it's not
just going to say no when you give it a
bite array which you probably should
offset every single bite do you want
just to rotate the whole battery by
three bytes that's just like
no no okay but listen listen if you give
it a text file it can it can do the
encryption
if it's given a single symbol yeah maybe
i think it should just do it on text if
it doesn't text it complains
okay so let's just
i think we're coming up with something
good here the only thing is what about
this name
historical
well i know but the problem is it there
isn't really a generate the whole point
about generate symmetric key
is that it has a mode in which it is
generating the key it isn't
this is a little bit of a different
operation because here if i say generate
symmetric key it goes from nothing to a
whole big key
right and generate symmetric key of
hello again goes from a password to
derive the key
right
whereas in this case there's not a lot
of generation going on it just is the
key
so if you have
a symmetric key for iis it does a random
byte array and here it will just give
you a random integer so it kind of does
generate something well
do you think you can do that
if you have generate cipher key and we
add the first argument which is a name
then uh we can say generate cipher key
and uh symmetric
it will be the same as generate
symmetric key with no arguments if you
say generate submit generate cipher key
symmetric comma hello would be the
second years so
it would fit nicely
well you're suggesting that we actually
allow
non-historical
stuff inside just functional yeah
[Music]
then people are just going to use that
function instead of using generate
symmetric key which is not what we want
right
because also somebody will end up with
something with password caesar and so on
i mean i guess this the syntax that you
have for generate cipher key is fine so
if you just say it it's for caesar it
gives you a random integer in cypher key
if you said caesar comma three it gives
you the cipher key object was the key
being three and for visioner you have
generate cipher key vision or comma
lemon
and then you have lemon as the key or
you just have visioner and then gives
you random string of
and then the question is do we want to
have a
way to specify the key lengths
provisioner we should have don't be the
third argument
also why isn't it just spaces
if you
want the key to be longer or am i
confused and it's a running key right
well you you just do using that
yeah but you can use lemon or you can
use london which is six or you can use a
long
but why can't you just see what you're
using i mean
so i guess we're talking about though i
mean
this is different from generate
symmetric key but it's probably
i think it's fine because in general
it's metric key it has all these cases
with passwords and derived keys and
stuff like that but here we're basically
saying that one you have to specify what
type of cipher it is because it's not
gonna you know what's it gonna do
default to caesar and then two
all of its arguments are just you know
they're just custom sets of arguments
that just get passed to the generating
functions for caesar or for you know
whatever other cipher you have yeah so
yeah
all right
this sounds sounds like a reasonable
thing so there may be some details let's
just look at the
um
at the guide page for cryptography there
is probably going to be a lot of details
like for example if i recall correctly
like the
function repository functions for like
caesar cipher they either ignore the
like specific characters you know that
have like
um
oh my god loudest or like yeah
i don't know i i that's probably an
option but i would suspect we should
pass them through unchanged but here's
another issue
encrypt returns an encrypted object but
don't you want the caesar cipher to
return us a string
maybe not maybe you want to return the
encryption
if you want to decrypt you have to know
what what the
cipher was
which is
encrypted object has the cipher and the
encrypted data so we can have this
encryption ciphered object that has
cipher goes to caesar data goes to
but wait hold on encrypted objects don't
have the cipher in them they usually
just have something like the the
initialization vector or something which
there isn't an initialization vector
here right
so i mean
well they have the they have the name of
the cipher that was used is that true
yeah but they don't need i mean they
don't need that do they because it's
it's like you know when you decrypt
you're going to have the key and then
the key
has that information
but this is more standard to have it if
you go and like er like rfcs the ways uh
like the encrypted data is passed
through like https
it usually contains the cipher name as
well right
it's kind of unnecessary right i mean
it's
i don't know i mean i feel like
i don't know i mean i feel like having
it return an encrypted object you then
have to kind of uh
extract the the string out of
uh it points out that you can include
the cipher name seems a little
unnecessary no but the point is if we
want the same workflow it's got to
return an encrypted object if we're
going to teach people the workflow by
using the caesar cipher it's got to
return an encrypted object
but what we could do
in the encrypted object
you know normally we just show this this
color thing maybe what we could do
is
put a preview of some of the text here
just as a way to kind of show
you know and that way
so that we get kind of the best of both
worlds we both have an encrypted object
that follows the standard workflow
and we have something that gives you an
indication of what that text you know
what the encrypted text looks like
we're going to have first few characters
or maybe instead of pictures
to show the
uh
yes that's possible maybe you know maybe
just wrap it around in like successive
lines now most of the rest of this
is irrelevant right there's nothing we
can do with any of these um
uh you know encrypt file decrypt file
they would work
well if it's a text file then it just
gets the string out of there
yes we could make it work
all right the red cipher key could also
generate symmetrical symmetric keeper
if you specify aes well um rsa for
example i would
disagree without doing that
yeah again i think that that just makes
it it just means that someone could have
a piece of code that just you know
instead of calling generate symmetra key
is calling this
i think any piece of code that does that
is is dangerous
because now you know you're mixing the
fake ciphers from the real ciphers if
you know what i mean
well so yeah without the argument that
um
we should not assume that in that the uh
encrypt works only with the real ciphers
because for educational purposes you may
want to consider weak
keys
just to show that they can be broken and
i think for educational purposes you
should keep them separate
right if you're generating a weak key
with uh
you know i don't know below fish or
something i think you can have small
keys blowfish like um
something like that you know
it's like you can already do that with
generate symmetrical you know i mean you
have to do a little bit of work to like
you know
tell it tell it to generate something
that's really small and
insecure but
you know it's it's
you're going to have to see if you had
that same capability inside of generate
cipher
general cipher q it would be just as as
sort of you'd have to specify just as
much stuff
this thing here
unless they're unicode characters for
that i don't think we're doing this
they might be
i have no idea
dancing figures like from the stronghold
i don't think this is this this is this
is very amusing
although no actually what it says about
remove die critics
so they just remove the umlauts and
things no that's why they don't bother
with them
these are nicely written things from
sander
very nice all right i think it's enough
said about that another question are we
gonna if if we do that and we document
it
are we to cite sunday
sure i mean no what we what we do is we
put things in the function repository
saying
this has now been included in whatever
so that's the usual way we do it
but so sorry this is one i mean what is
the name going to be generate cipher key
or generate historical cipher key
generate cipher key by the time you
typed in caesar's name there
if you don't know that it's historical
yeah
but
um
you know i don't believe i ever heard
this word visionaire you you you were
pronouncing that doria i don't think i
ever heard i've only i've only seen it
it's a french scientist i know that i
know that yeah i i mean i know the
history i just have only seen it written
um i think it usually has like a
diacritic on the
yes yes
yes
[Music]
fair enough um
hey when is your cryptography course
coming coming out
it's like almost done it's in
post-production we're having a study
group
and
starting january 31st
cool
and the mooc itself is probably going
somewhere
maybe a week or two later because they
are
putting it all together yeah actually
almost there
excellent okay
okay all right let's move on to our next
topic here
um
can i drop then yes thank you very much
see ya
see you bye